PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's take another look
at the Monty Hall tree
that we worked
with to figure out
the probability of the
switch strategy winning.
Now this tree was just
absolutely literal
and absurdly complicated
and large for what
we're trying to analyze.
That is, we literally
thought of each
of the three outcomes of whether
the prize was behind door one,
door two, door three,
and then exactly which
door the contestant picked
next-- either door one, door
two, door three, and so on.
And it's clear that this tree
has a symmetric structure.
That is, these three
sub-trees-- whether the prize
is behind one, the
prize is behind two,
or the prize is behind three--
all have the same structure.
And we could have gotten
away with analyzing one,
and deduced that that's what
happened with the other two
branches.
In fact, that really
was what we did.
But why not make that
explicit in our analysis
from the first place?
Instead of it having
this triple tree,
let's just look at the
tree with one branch.
So there's the central
branch that I'm keeping.
Namely, we're assuming
that the first move is
to have the prize at door
two, and then the door
picked has three choices.
And then the door opened has
two choices or one, depending
on where the prize was placed
relative to the contestant's
pick here.
If the prize was at two, and
the contestant picked door two,
then Carol has a choice of two
doors-- one or three-- to open.
On the other hand, if
the prize was at two,
and the contestant
picked door one,
Carol has no choice but to open
door three with probability 1.
OK.
Now when we're
looking at this tree,
the first branch is kind
of fixed and forced.
So we don't really need it
as part of the analysis.
What we're really
looking at is analyzing
what happens in the experiment
starting at the stage
where the contestant
picks a door.
So let's just enlarge this tree
to get a better look at it.
There's the same tree
where we're starting off,
where we're assuming that
the prize is at door two,
and then the door picked
can be either door one, door
two, or door three,
and the door opened
then can be door three, door
one, door three, or door one
according to the
constraints on Carol.
Now a better way to understand
this tree [? as ?] instead
of saying the prize
is at door two,
and this is where the
contestant chooses door two,
and then have to worry about
all the other branches that
are symmetrically like this,
we could have reformulated
the tree model in the
first place by saying,
let's just consider the cases
that wherever the prize is,
there are three possibilities.
The contestant picks the
door where their prize is,
or they pick the
next door-- let's
say in some counter-clockwise
direction from where
the prize is.
Or going around among
the doors in a circle,
they pick a door
that's two doors away
from where the prize is.
And if we reformulate
it that way,
then these are the cases--
either the contestant picks
the prize door, or they
pick the first door that
doesn't have the prize, or
they pick the second door
that doesn't have the prize.
And each of those occur
with probability of 1/3.
And likewise, once they've
picked door number one
with no prize, then
that means that Carol
has the choice of only one
door that she can open,
because the other
unpicked door has a prize.
So she's got to open the
second no-prize door,
because the contestant has
picked the first no-prize door.
Likewise, if the contestant
picks the prize door,
Carol can pick either
of the non-prize door--
non-prize one or non-prize two.
Both are losses.
And likewise here, where
Carol's move is forced,
and the contestant will win.
So now we're in great shape,
because I've really gotten rid
of the rest of the tree.
It's not as though I'm
analyzing 1/3 of it,
and the 1/3 analysis is going
to apply to the other parts
by symmetry.
But I've captured
the whole story here
by simply relativizing the
first move instead of it
being literally door one,
door two, door three.
I don't care what actual
door the contestant picks.
All I care about is whether
the contestant picks the prize
door, or the first door
that's not the prize door,
or the second door that's
not the prize door.
This would have been
a much better tree
to start off with the
first place, at least
for the purpose of analyzing
the probability of winning.
Now we're going to
get some mileage out
of the more complicated tree
in a later video segment
when we start talking about
conditional probabilities
of what are the probabilities
of things happening
at various stages
in the experiment.
And so we will want to have some
of these other vertices that
represent stages
of the experiment.
But if we'd really
been thinking solely
about how to analyze the
probability of winning
with the switch
strategy, this would've
been a much better
tree to start off with.
But wait.
Let's look at this tree.
First of all, there
really isn't any need
to model this branch
of the experiment,
because at this point, once
we're talking about switching,
if the contestant has
picked a non-prize door,
they win-- period.
Carol's move is forced,
and it's going to be a win.
We might have well just
collapsed the win down
to say that as soon as they pick
a non-prize door they've won,
and who cares what
happens after that?
Same thing down here.
So the tree really
could've simplified to one
where you pick a no-prize
door and you win,
you pick the other no-prize
door and you win, or you
pick a prize door,
and then Carol
has a choice of opening either
of the other two no-prize
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
Because after all,
what's the point
in distinguishing between
whether you pick prize door
one, or you pick prize door two?
You win in both cases.
And really, all
we care about, we
could have condensed the
entire tree down to one
where either you pick the
prize door with probability
of 1/3, in which case
you're guaranteed
to lose no matter what happens.
Or you pick the
non-prize door, which
you do with probability
2/3, in which case
you win no matter what happens.
And that is a really
simple tree, OK?
There it is.
And what we can
read off immediately
is that with the switch strategy
the probability of winning
is 2/3.
So the switch wins if and
only if the prize door is not
picked.
And that means that the
probability that switch wins
is 2/3, which is what we
already figured out using
the more complicated tree.
But this way of getting
at it is a lot clearer.
So the message here is that
the tree that you come up
with to model the
experimental outcomes
is really a modeling process.
And there may be
many models that work
to capture a given scenario.
And it will often pay off to
try to find a simpler tree
to make the analysis simpler.